[موسيقى]
تعاني روسيا العديد من المشكلات فيما
يتعلق بتصدير السلاح حاليا كما ان هناك
عقوبات مفروضه عليها من دول الغرب ما يجعل
انتاج السلاح اكثر صعوبه على روسيا كما
يتعرض المشترون المحتملون والحاليون
للسلاح الروسي لضغط لعدم الشراء وهذا
الضغط من الاوروبيين وكذلك امريكا
[موسيقى]
المستفاده من هذه الحرب وهي ان السلاح
الروسيه لا يبدو على درجه جيده من الكفاءه
كما ان صناعه السلاح في روسيا مشغوله
حاليا لانتاج السلاح لاستخدامها الخاص ما
يترك صناعه السلاح للتصدير تفتقر للوقت
وفي السنه المقبله سنشهد تراجعا اضافيا
على صادرات السلاح الروسي
[موسيقى]
نجاحات ملحوظه في السنوات الاخيره خاصه في
بيع طائراتها المقاتله التي لم يكن عليها
طلب في السابق وفي الوقت ذاته تتراجع
مبيعات روسيا وبالتالي ستتساويان قريبا
وكما نعلم من طلبات الشراء الحاليه نجد ان
فرنسا لديها طلبات تفوق بكثير الطلبات من
روسيا
[موسيقى]
وقعوا ان فرنسا ستتجاوز روسيا خلال نحو
ثلاث سنوات لتصبح ثانيه اكبر دوله مصدره
للسلاح اي تتقدم فرنسا وتتراجع روسيا
[موسيقى]